je suis dans le quartier de la roseraie
à angers où je suis venu rencontrer
gringo mariana et leurs familles qui
vivent ici sur ce parking d'un ensemble
hlm bonjour gringo merci de répondre à
mes questions est ce que vous pouvez me
décrire vos conditions de vie ici alors
nos conditions de vie c'est des
conditions très difficiles
parce qu'on en est avec nos quatre
enfants qu'on aura dans une caravane qui
n'est pas adaptée ça à faire en moins de
trois mois qu'on a fait une demande de
logement mais voilà quoi on veut pas non
vous vous êtes apatrides vous n'avez pas
de nationalité et c'est ce qui vous
empêche de trouver un travail alors que
pourtant vous recherchez bien un travail
mon rêve c'est de pouvoir travailler ça
peut vraiment nous sortir de notre moi
j'ai fait une demande d'avoir mes
papiers la préfecture en fait me
demander
des preuves de majorer depuis toute la
majorité en france et moi c'est
malheureux à dire mais je peux pas
trouver ces problèmes quoi alors que moi
en fait j'ai jamais quitté la france ça
fait combien de temps vous êtes en
france
mes parents ont fui la guerre des
balkans
on est venu en france en 95 moi je suis
arrivé en france quand j'étais bébé je
suis français en fait moi je me sens
français à la base parce que moi j'ai
fait ma scolarité j'ai dit mais tous mes
certificats scolaire en france la seule
chose que je demande de la france c'est
pas grand chose
c'est à voir mes papiers pour pouvoir
travailler pour pouvoir faire un futur
pour mes enfants côté
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous
vivez ici avec votre famille quoi ici
sur ce parti
troisième phase et on n'a nulle part où
aller ce n'est pas qu'on veut rester sur
un parking on n'a nulle part où aller
[Musique]
bon alors expliquez-moi un petit peu
comment est ce que vous vivez ici au
quotidien avec vos quatre enfants dans
cette caravane
ben c'est pas facile en réalité parce
que c'est une caravane qui est prévu
pour quatre 4 personnes alors que nous à
l'intérieur on est à 6 vous disposez à
peu près de combien par mois pour faire
vos courses pour le gaz pour combien ce
que vous arrivez à obtenir par mois sont
100 100 euros par mois c'est l'aide de
l'état qu'on en fait entre les enfants
moi ma femme et mes beaux parents on est
au total vite en fait et je peux vous
garantir c'est que
c'est vraiment vraiment pas facile car
la viande pour nous c'est du luxe en
fait c'est vraiment du luxe qu'est ce
que vous achetez en général quand vous
faites vos courses dans général c'est
d'ailleurs pour les enfants
c'est du pin et demi qu'on peut le
conserver c'est des pâtes en plus le gaz
le pétrole tout ce qui est râlant pas
dire ca le prix auront augmenté et une
bouteille de gaz entre 30 et 40 euros en
fait ben c'est pas beaucoup d'argent
mais pour nous qui nous n'avons pas de
travail en fait c'est beaucoup d'argent
vous allez faire comment là du coup par
exemple ben
là sûrement sûrement marianne en fait on
va aller faire la manche pour pouvoir
acheter une bouteille de gaz
[Musique]
djamel blanchard vous êtes militants des
quartiers populaires vous avez aidé vous
continuer à aider cette famille comment
est-ce qu'il s'en sorte d'abord je veux
saluer la solidarité qu'on a sur le
quartier de la rose est à recommencer
qu'il s'en sorte mais justement c'est
toujours l'interrogation conte à chaque
jour en fait il n'a pas le lendemain
s'ils vont pouvoir être pour manger à
leur faim avoir ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir se préparer à l'hiver donc aussi
dérangé que habité de manière permanente
dans un beat alternative dans une
caravane c'est un cas de la salubrité
publique on a une chasse aux pauvres qui
effectué pour ceux qui ont le moins que
si on a moins qui sont oubliés de
trouver à d'habitat alternatif pour
pouvoir se mettre à l'abri et on
considère avec les bailleurs publics hlm
maintenant que on doit chasser du pot
convocation du pauvre n'a ni violence
institutionnelle qui s'inscrit à travers
une audience au tribunal qu'est ce qui
leur est reproché est exactement à cette
famille alors y'a rien de délictuelles
en l'occurrence qui leur est reproché
c'est d'occuper une petite place de
parking en plus de ça qui est très
discrète qui est très réservé et qui
n'étaient pas occupés on en est rendu là
quand même rendu avec des office public
hlm dont une mission de service public
pour permettre à des gens qui en
logements et en l'occurrence la famille
qui est ici qui vivaient sous tente à la
rue ont fait une demande de logement on
ne l'a rendue avec un office public hlm
qui se permet de demander 200 euros dalé
nisation mensuel d'une place de parking
c'est pour vous dire pour moi ce que
considère une extorsion de fonds
carrément cessé l'escroquerie et c'est
pour ça qu'on ne doit pas justement nous
abdiqué et se mettre à genoux devant des
politique nauséabonde qui considère que
des gens qui ont le moins doivent subir
le plus